while Luke John was a developer at seven
West media he led the adoption of CSS in
jeaious at the West Australian and at
Perth now and he's also a leading
contributor to the CSS in J's framework
glamorous he's going to tell us all
about using CSS nsj we have type systems
like typescript or flow with typesafe
CSS and J yes please welcome look okay
so as you just heard I'm here today to
talk about type safety and CSS and Jas
both of which are very shiny quite new
and a really fun to work with so just a
bit of background around how we got to
type safety and CSS and Jas we've had
this massive rise of Jas everywhere
we've got frameworks like react and
angular and as those frameworks got
bigger and more mature we've started to
see type systems from the likes of
Facebook and Microsoft where you'll have
some level of type safety with your
JavaScript and that language will just
compile to JavaScript and it helps make
those large code bases a bit more marine
table and flexible for a future usage so
on the CSS nsj side of things we should
probably start with what CSS outside JSS
with these modern frameworks where
you're doing component based development
your markup is a function of state it's
quite easy to understand based on this
URL and flowing through your JSX if
you're using react exactly what markup
you're going to be getting when it comes
to styling side of things it's a bit
more of an unknown a lot of frameworks
we'll be having will be important
perhaps for different CSS external files
then they might be using webpack loaders
for sass to have some level of component
based styling but the CSS is not
necessarily determinable
based on just state CSS in jeaious both
your markup and your styling is a
function of your state and so based on a
URL or a user being logged in you can
work out exactly what styles and only
those styles are actually created for
the page so it enables pattern things
like critical CSS and really helps out
if you're doing server-side rendering to
only shoot down the CSS which is needed
for any particular page so it's really
awesome so as we started there before a
lot of this talk is going to be using
react however CSS in jeaious exists with
a bunch of the other frameworks now but
when you add type safety to something
like react and CSS nsj you start to live
in the happily ever after where things
are really shiny and you won't enjoy
coding all the things and so we'll just
start with where CSS nsj started the
term was first popularized by inline
styles in react where as you're doing
your templating inside your JSX there
there's a style property available which
you can just add some inline Styles
those will get added in line in your
resulting HTML markup but then later on
other frameworks saw that pattern
thought this is really awesome and they
created some other handy helpers that
would extract all of that and put it
into your head or do other things but
the basic pattern was very similar and
this example here is actually got it
turned on with typescript we'll just
have a look at the Taipings for where we
started with type safety in CSS and
jeaious they just typed a subset of CSS
properties for some of them they had
pretty strong type safeties so this
aligned content property here you'll get
autocomplete on the key and the value
and if you do a misspelling which
is quite common in CSS you'll get
immediate feedback about that
unfortunately there's a lot of CSS
properties that allow quite flexible
values border 10px solid red
you can't give types a key for that sort
of thing just using this pattern so
they're just type two strings so this
was the inline Styles popularized by
react what was happening in Jay s about
the same time is the language was
getting new features one particular new
features were template literals of which
the more advanced version was the tagged
template literals and these would allow
you to pass template literals with
function that's at bottom one that's
just grad from MD n n MD end the
examples and so people who were doing a
lot of react development who had
traditionally been putting a lot of work
into other solutions for CSS at scale
saw this and thought wow we could do
some really awesome stuff with this that
slide is far too small to see on
apologize but essentially you've got a
function up the top there that you've
set up which would allow users to use a
string as an API for writing their CSS
within JavaScript and then have
expressions within that of course this
is a bit of a back step when it comes to
type safety for CSS and jeaious because
we've gone back to a string interface
and you're not going to get a lot of
safety there however really popularized
the props based styling pattern where
you could have functions which you could
pass props to so when you're doing
component based development pass props
in to what was ever creating your CSS
and rather than having three different
class names that you're going to select
form based on those props you could just
write the exact CSS in
case which was really handy and here's
just an example using styled components
you get auto complete on the Dom tags of
the interface but then once you're
inside that tag template you have no
real safety but then down below there
what you can see is using so that then
returns a react component which you can
just use inside your JSX see inside your
templating and it has the props flowing
through quite nicely so then we had
glamorous came out earliest last year I
think about April and it followed on
from some of the api's that had been
pioneered by the starred components
people but they quite liked the CSS
object interface for writing your CSS so
they mixed that pattern of having
component factories with CSS objects and
this was really exciting for where I was
working at the time we had been using
processes peer-review conventions such
as been to protect our code base from
bad things happening and this was
working for most of the time for our
front-end devs with strong CSS knowledge
however that wasn't all of us we had
people with a range of experience across
domains and so bad things were still
happening CSS nsj with something quite
glamorous which we would be able to type
look like it offered some technical
solutions to the problems we were having
so the initial typings somebody was
obviously using it on a project they'd
ridden some type-ins internally and they
went to contribute that back to the
community
what had been happening a lot at that
time was people would put the tie pins
on definitely typed and just sort of
which is a it's a repo set up by
Microsoft which makes all the types of
ailable to install but about this time
people were starting to bundle
definitions with the frame
so somebody thought oh yeah I'll try and
get those landed there the person who
led the development of it wasn't quite
sure about it but the feedback he got
and it's quite surely is that it's a lot
better for consumers when you have
bundle typed it implies that the project
is type friendly B those bundle types
flow or type script and when you change
or add something you can expect a PR
shortly to add type support for that and
a bunch of other things it does however
lead to a bit of extra contributor
overhead because you've got more
activity going on
so those initial definitions they just
covered a small subset about the of the
API of glamorous and there was also a
clear expectation set around how those
types would be maintained it would be up
to typescript users to maintain those
which was everybody accepted and was
great what was also very helpful was the
project had very clear contribution
guidelines this provided clear guidance
for the initial PR to add them but also
for anybody who wanted to extend the
Taipings or add additional features it
was very clear how they could add those
features and get them landed so if
you're adding types to a framework
highly recommend having contribution
guidelines well laid out so initially it
was set up with the types separated out
into a toppings folder which is a fairly
standard thing with in typescript
definitions and also flow ones and then
there's just a field you put in your
package jason with a the location of
where the toppings are for when
typescript does type acquisition on
usage and it also just had a simple test
file the way testing works for a lot of
typescript definitions is that they just
have a single file that just goes to all
the uses that the types provide and make
sure that the compiler doesn't generate
any error output and as you can imagine
there's some problems with that but
we'll touch on that in a bit
and so sorry
so showing up there fantastic
so this is just some of the api's that
glamorous had to give an idea as we jump
into the Tri Keynes that it has what
sort of support it needed and the range
of types so we just start with some
glamorous dom and built-in component
factories the second signature their
glamorous talk gives just a short cut to
the first one it also had built-in
components so you could just import a
div from glamorous name name sized
exports and also glamorous octave would
work as well
this actually presented a bit of
challenge for typescript because there's
no easy way to share named exports with
interfaces for typing so there was a
fair bit of type ii plication also with
the glamorous stock dev for the other
built in component factories then
glamorous could also take components
when you set up a component factory so
that needed to be typed and it also had
options which would then change the
behavior of the resulting component so
if you set that props are CSS overrides
this equal to true when you finally use
that component you then have available
all of the CSS properties as props on
that component which will get added up
into the CSS and then there's also with
component api which you can change what
component the eventuated clamorous
component factory returns so a huge api
service with things at the top level
impacting things a few levels down which
was quite interesting so in terms of
type coverage we'll just touch on
initially the CSS and SVG properties so
we'll start with the these were very
similar to the react typings
initially we just used to react to CSS
property typings then we had a great PR
from a contributor who vendored those
but then went through property by
property and checking the MDM doc
tation and tightening up the types so
for some things such as display or float
I think where the reactor eye pins for
would just accept any string it was
tightened up a bit so for the
autocomplete it was really helpful and
for misspellings it would avoid that
then we just also need to support the
pseudo properties so that's how you
would use that and then when you're
using that anywhere where it's being
typed you're going to get type safety
which is really handy you also get
autocomplete it's quite wonderful then
we had a lossy version of the CSS
properties the way that a lot of the CSS
and J's frameworks work with their CSS
objects is they support something
similar to sass and other things where
you can have contextual selectors but
also just for media queries where you
have another object underneath it
because of this particular type index
that would be getting added onto it it
meant that for the previous CSS objects
you actually lose type safety so whilst
if you've typed float correctly get type
safety on the properties in order to
complete if you accidentally type flat
it's going to pass which is a bit sad
there are some other alternative CSS and
J's frameworks that have alternative
syntax for this sort of stuff they're
not quite as widely adopted or and but
should be interesting in the future and
so then just using it all together it's
kind of like CSS it's just using an
object J object syntax it all fits
together quite well so those are just
some examples so style arguments these
are the things that when we saw earlier
on the glamorous API you would set up a
component Factory with either a Dom tag
or a component these are the arguments
that you then pass to that to create
your CSS it can take a function which
would return some properties or a string
or also an array of properties and
strings it would also accept a style
array so
ray of all of those things and then a
style argument sort of a combination of
those plus a couple of other signatures
that I've just taken out of that for
brevity's sake but then for the style
arguments that's for dynamic styles and
you can see their props are getting
passed to us and generic so that they're
available in the style functions a lot
of the time when you do in CSS in j/s
you won't actually use props flowing
through and so there's also a simpler
static style argument which also helps
out with the compiler output if
something goes wrong it's a bit simpler
in those cases it's been easier to read
and so here's an example of how those
types are then checked on a component so
here that will pass because it's a CSS
properties object and the values are
correct here this would pass because
it's a function having actually typed
this but it the props if I had a typed
on the example component would be type
two something and then you can use that
in determining the output of the display
here it would pass because it's going to
return a string here would pass because
it's going to return an array of all
those things so quite a lot of different
things you could do with star arguments
Oh with support and so we'll next look
at just a single one of the glamorous
API shapes that we saw earlier where you
pass a component factory to the
glamorous function which will return you
a glamorous component Factory so this is
a heavily trimmed down version of the
types so we start with the main export
from the definitions which is this
glamorous interface then the glamorous
interface
this looks really noisy and messy
essentially it's just a object which
takes a component with some optional
objects and returns a glamorous
component factories we've had to use a
lot of generics here because of all the
different changes that happen downstream
in that glamorous can
Factory and then the resulting Columbus
component that is created from that in
order to get type safety there but you
don't actually have to pass any of those
generics all the time most of the time
if you're doing something dynamic with
that component you'll just pass the
props and the rest will just all match
together
if you've typed it on that component
which is really nice we use overloading
with this signature because depending on
the options that you pass in again the
signature of the so dish the API of the
resulting glamorous component is quite
different it will accept if you've set
the props or CSS overrides options to
true a bit down you can just use those
props and so they need to be typed as
well so that's the initial creation then
we get into the actual component factory
so that returns the component factory
component factories just take those
generic crops and initially we start
with a overload for the static styles we
put that at the top because even though
it should match down the bottom as well
so the next two we'll see there was a
bit of a memory leak issue with
typescript and this just has CSS
properties as arguments pretty much you
can't do any functions or anything in
there then we have an overload for a few
props have got a theme so there's a
concept of a theme provider and
glamorous which I won't go into but
essentially there's some magical props
that can end up on that component and be
available for whilst you do in your
styling and we also use as part of this
so we say that when they set up the
props for the component Factory so for
those functions that we turn the styles
the themes going to be available but
then when they we actually return the
glamorous component from this all those
props that are there they need to be set
up
but the theme doesn't type script
doesn't have subtraction types and it
kind of gives something similar but it
does actually pollute the intellisense
and compiler output so I would recommend
avoiding where possible and then finally
we just have a overload for the
component factory where there's just
that props no theme which is quite handy
and it just keeps the types of it's
simpler and then finally the component
factory to returns a glamorous component
which is just a react component factory
with various external props and extra
glamorous props so the external props in
some case will just be the props
sometimes it will be the CSS properties
if we had offset that props or CSS
overrides earlier on and then it also
has some methods available on it such as
with component which we saw earlier
which will let you have all the props
and all the type in but for a slightly
different component which is this one
here and there's a couple of other ones
there so what was getting typing typed
initially it started off with just a
very small subset of what was available
in glamorous it was quite understandable
easy to use but there was a lot of stuff
that you couldn't do then we started to
add overloads and generics to provide
support for both the alternative
interfaces but also the generics to get
better type safety on some things that
initially that were essentially such as
pops just a any so you didn't have that
much safety then we introduced the omit
type to support the theme being excluded
it seems like a really good idea at the
time there was probably an alternative
syntax that we could have used using an
additional generic but this less magical
type and had we have used that it would
have led to much cleaner compiler output
and when users are having errors easy to
understand what's going on and then
eventually we started having to use
overloads coupled with generics which
would extend the extend from things so
that we could limit this particular
generic to
this shape and then we'll do this thing
and it all got very complicated very
fast that was a very small subset in
some places there were extra overloads
for things like CSS properties versus
SVG properties unfortunately a
limitation of the compiler typescript
compiler at this point in time meant
that the intellisense at this point in
time meant that if you try and union
that there you would just lose
autocomplete it would still type but the
developer experience would get worse and
so pretty massive amount of types as you
can imagine things go wrong when you've
got such large types and the standard
definition strategy of just testing what
is meant to work and making sure that
the compiler succeeds wasn't really
sufficient to allow additional
contributors to easily add things and
not have to worry about accidentally
breaking something else so we introduced
some additional testing we just set up a
should fail file adjacent to the test
file and then we just used just
snapshotting to run the compiler on that
file as well make sure that everything
that we'd set up to fail was ending up
in that snapshot and that did pick up
quite regularly where people would sort
of think oh I can just make this change
here and not realize that that would
actually knock out something else with
one of the other glamorous interfaces so
really handy pattern there's some other
strategies there now that a little less
sort of hacky here we're just using
spawn to run the compiler and snapshot
it but definitely recommend testing both
sides and also just on the testing side
of things you'll often find that if
you're using
glamorous as part of something that else
which you're generating definitions from
it has subtly different behavior with
the compiler so recommend testing in
definitions declarations bode with your
tests another thing that we did
with the types in some places was we did
things that weren't strictly necessary
but they improved the developer
experience in one case if we used a
union for type the you would get type
safety but when you're using vs code or
another editor that's using Intel a
sense you would lose autocomplete which
was really handy feature and people who
aren't using typescript are also getting
benefits off it so we would do some sort
of happy things it's worthwhile
commenting when you do that to make sure
that in a couple of months time both
flow and typescript moving really
rapidly a lot of things this one we
found after about two months we could
actually just move to a spread under
Union and it all worked nicely so worth
commenting those things sometimes you
need to get a bit creative when you're
setting up types as well or using it
with the type system we had a fun one
where the rollout compilation for
glamorous was incompatible with how
typescript was doing the importing so we
actually added this this to the main
glamorous source file just to allow
usage with typescript but where you do
get creative with things like this again
it's really worthwhile adding some
comments so that the next person knows
what's going on and it's a pretty
massive amount of typing there a large
surface area with the API there were
some pretty massive mistakes that were
made which were in most cases quite
avoidable a couple of those one we had
this issue opened up it was quite an
interesting one so there was a memory
leak with the Taipings
which meant that when you were using
that with a project with a lot of
glamorous components pretty quickly the
compiler would bath and you would get
out of memory that was it was
interesting because the compiler worked
fine with tests and depending on project
size and also usage of the types it
would just never show up and the way
that it
part of why it happened was there a
bunch of changes the types getting added
to a V next branch so nobody was testing
them in production
all of a sudden V next launched there
were all these new types that landed and
how they interacted led to this man we
liked so it took a few days to sort of
work out where that was and get an
update going another one was the
definitions can sometimes get quite
overwhelming this was a very politely
worded issue from somebody where they
had gone to use the glamorous with
typescript and the autocomplete was just
out of control
as you start to type in the arguments
you would get this enormous window pop
up with all the different options and it
would hijack your arrow keys as to go
through the different options so this
one was quite well in some ways easily
solved went back in and we structured
some of the Taipings
so that the output for things like Intel
he sense but also just compiler output
if there's an error was more readable
and more clear more concise and yeah so
definitely recommend limiting type
coverage when you're typing the
framework like this if the framework
doesn't in tender usage
don't type it there were a couple of PRS
landed early on that were landed purely
to supports and some stuff that had
started happening by mistake and was
never really intended by the framework
or the lead contributors and because
that got typed early it's hard to remove
type coverage for anything that you've
added because people will complain when
they do a update and things break for a
non-major also try to ensure types don't
make workflows difficult like you can
tell you senses you just saw and should
always use comments to help consumers
this will win you a lot of love for both
typescript
and flow in just j/s developers because
in things like intellisense for api's
that are immediately clear just off the
name of that property they get a little
bit of actually information about how to
use it it's also really important with
this sort of thing to enable
contributors something really awesome
that's happened in the last year is that
there's now online play boxes where you
can set up a full type script and flow
project and import glamorous and have
the sort of definitions being used as
you're typing online and getting error
output in browser so setting up a
sandbox for people who are having issues
to be able to quickly set up a
reproduction along with the issue rather
than having us set up a whole repo and
it's really handy and also just obvious
things like asking for the version of
typescript they're using if they are
having an issue with the bundle
declarations is really handy so we'll
now just have a quick look at how you
use the CSS MJS which i've script and so
here we have a glamorous component
factory with styles where we're getting
autocomplete on both the property name
and then the values that it accepts
really handy really useful we'll jump
straight from that to this is something
we're going to now create with CSS nsj
and typescript
so it's a reproduction of the LCA
schedule where the it starts at a
calendar then just collapse down to a
talk by talk by talk and gives us some
really clean HTML without lots of
wrapping divs or reused CSS or anything
like that so we'll start with a
timetable react component which if we
jump into that and have a look at that's
just a glamorous emotion component
Factory another CSS nsj framework
we've got our CSS being returned from
this we're going to use the CSS grid
we're able to use the props that that's
being typed with which has a number of
active rooms to set up the amount of
columns that we want on that so then if
we jump back to the time table inside of
that time table we're going to have time
starts which is just going to show up on
the left hand side as we saw and pass
that through the information it needs to
do that and it's just another react
component which then has the time start
h3 and then that's going to use the
props to set up the CSS to put it in
there collect correct row which is nice
and handy there and the correct column
as well then we'll jump on to the slot
so that's the actual talks as we go
through they're going to have a use
another component we'll just have a look
at the styled slot we won't go through
all of it
that takes a bunch of props which go
into the styling again I've collapsed
this so it doesn't include all the
stylings required but it's going to grab
the using the room index it's going to
run another method which gets room
colored that just takes a CSS color
value and adjusts the hue left and right
so that we get the nice colors going
along and we can have sort of infinite
amount of rooms or just a few and then
it's going to select the column and the
amount of rows that talk should span
based on its twine start and it's time
offset so as we've been going through
here only the CSS that is absolutely
required for each of these slots is
being generated in cases where the CSS
is in common it will dilute those Styles
automatically for that use so there's no
need for by handy chipping it will be
producing a really nice clean markup
there's no need for wrapping divs to
sort of enable this kind of nice visual
structure and it's
really really easy and fast so this
whole thing took about 20 minutes to get
running which normally with CSS would
take an enormous what might take a bit
longer to get all of those grids and
calls if you weren't doing it inside of
j/s and being able to use those patterns
so just have a look at the future of CSS
MJS and some of the things that type
script and flow enabling and the first
one this is very limited to typescript
in particular there's this really cool
thing called typescript server plugins
which gives you that string api for CSS
that we talked about earlier on when
that first came around
there's no way to type a string these
server plugins actually allow you to
create your own sort of type safety for
certain things and give autocomplete in
editors using intellisense and whatnot
so here we're actually getting type safe
CSS strings in j/s which is really
powerful and I think very exciting for
the future there's also some plays
around how you generate types at the
moment for glamorous as you saw there
was the glamorous dev Col glamorous with
the div string there was the export so
import did from glamorous there was the
glamorous dot uppercase div which are
all doing fairly similar stuff and using
the same sets of types but they have to
be typed separately and so we've
generated typings
you can sort of automate some of that
which both makes it a bit easier for
contributors when they want to make a
change to some of those big files they
can just make it in one place but also
gives you a bit more confidence in the
definitions because as it is there's a
fair bit of copy pasting these are just
for the different files each of which
are a couple of hundred lines long
another really exciting thing regex try
there's a PR open on the typescript
repository at the moment it's probably
not going to land for a couple of major
couple of versions but it's been
actively discussed by the typescript
team and looks really exciting
not just for CSS in jeaious but a whole
range of other applications and so this
isn't actually necessary this isn't
anything to do with typescript and CSS
in jeaious this is just really cool
things you can do CSS and j/s because
it's so shiny you can do CSS
snapshotting alongside your markup for
your components so if you have things go
wrong it's easier to pick up in peer
review and also just whilst you're
developing traditionally your Yui
snapshots might contain a couple of
class names which you may or may not
have set and really no information about
the style rules but this sort of opens
up a lot more confidence it does
generate very noisy tests however which
brings us to visual snapshots we're on a
unit level it's really easy when you're
using something like CSS in j/s to test
that that component is pixel perfect for
changes so what you can see here and
isn't working is actually you'd never
see that if you were just looking at it
in PR by running the code but here on
the bottom one something it's just a
couple of pixels off and you pick that
stuff up immediately it's really really
amazing
so just summarize some of the points
we've touched on type systems really
help keep code maintainable and really
help enable growth of applications when
you think about CSS in G is a really
nice way to think about it is it's
turning it's adding the styling to be a
function of the state in addition to
your markup you can do inline Styles you
can have styles throw an app into your
head you can do both string an object as
an API
and you've now got type safety with both
of them thanks to things like the server
plugins the component factories really
enable you as a developer with component
based dev to have props impact your
styling in terms of when you're actually
setting up definitions and declarations
for frameworks developers love them it's
useful if you keep the type simple it
both helps the users and also helps
people who want to contribute be able to
contribute and should test types fail as
well as succeed it sounds really obvious
but within the typescript and also flow
communities the way that testing is
happening currently that is not as
common as it should be you can type a
lot more than you think but you probably
shouldn't it'll just make it harder for
people to use the types and contribute
to them in the future
compilers aren't perfect but there's
lots of ways to work around them and
yeah types should enable users and not
overwhel them if you're interested in
CSS MJS there's a excellent repo on
github CSS in Jas 101 I highly recommend
checking it out
it has a thorough overview of all the
different options that are out there
currently how you would use them and the
advantages of the various options these
are also some great people to follow on
Twitter Basara in particular when it
comes to typescript he wrote a CSS and
J's framework with just typescript and
is really excellent and all of the other
ones
Kent Dodds is the creator of glamorous
and the other people out there have
created other CSS and J's frameworks
really awesome people and thank you very
much and that is CSS and J's and type
safety
and I think we've just got a little bit
of time for questions that thing that's
yep
so which generates I think the question
was we've generated tycoons what's the
best way to do that currently where
you've got various variations but with
common things I haven't actually done
that yet there's some interesting ones
I think ts spoon was one and a few
others but there's also things like
babel prevail where if you just have
some code that you want to use to
generate other code on build enable that
quite easily but I haven't actually
dived into that yet it just looks really
exciting